all right thank you very much
hey lily come here honey
hi
do you know what this is a box uh
containing she doesn't know containing
well that's how she learns new words by
us using them or that's how we lower
self-esteem by bombarding her with
confusing vocabulary what's the wealth
containing told you okay it's your dress
it's finally here
it's every little girl's dream to be a
flower girl in a wedding it's lily's
chance to shine i was a three-time ring
bearer
it's lily's chance to shine
oh no cam cam she's gonna look like
little bo peep or little bow cheap look
at this fabric it's already pilling
maybe you'll look better on you mean
turned on no it does not come
i love it no you don't oh my gosh are we
really gonna let her wear this you know
what if the bride wants to have a tacky
wedding she can have a tacky wedding
lily will be the bright spot literally
heard it as soon as i said it
and it's this
and it's this
not this
but this okay okay that's good cam safe
let's save some petals for lily all
right let's do it over here sweetie okay
there you go oh like you're coming down
the aisle yeah okay
not too many at once you're doing great
lil she is isn't she forget the bride
all the eyes are gonna be on her
[Music]
i cannot believe you laughed i am sorry
but you know i have two weaknesses
children cursing and old people rapping
cam we have to tell her it's a bad word
no that just gives it more power the
less we make of it the better let's just
pretend like it never happened okay well
you know maybe it maybe it didn't maybe
we maybe we misheard yeah
maybe she said truck or duck
or luck she could have said yuck daddy
give me some ice cream no honey if
you're hungry you can have some fruit
fruit
i have two children
do you have any idea what station this
is oh here i'll look online it's a
webcast that would have been helpful to
know 900 channels ago no it's on public
access or something i want to watch that
claire okay well first honey we need to
talk about something it's about that
word you said this morning
what word you know the one that starts
with f
flower no
fruit no if she doesn't remember it we
shouldn't remind her oh she said it
three times oh you mean
cam leave the room
nope i can do this
lily that is a bad word and you are not
allowed to say it ever but it makes you
laugh okay well daddy shouldn't be
laughing and you should never say that
word
do you understand maybe
okay this is not a game all right if you
say that word one more time i'm gonna
take away all your toys i'm serious she
knows i'm not serious
what about the wedding but what if she
says it there she's like a ticking time
bomb what are we gonna do cancel yes
maybe we just call and say we're not
going to any more weddings until the
gays can get married oh so now we're
political we leave town on gay pride
weekend because we don't like the
traffic
please be seated
[Music]
friends family
thank you really
well you know i cry at weddings
oh no what a glorious day stop stop
crying but just because you have ice
water in your veins doesn't mean no no
lily
n no lily he's fine oh daddy's not sad
daddy daddy
[Laughter]
see
i told you it was funny
uh
[Music]
you